there's no statute against photos on the
electric why are you taking pictures my
question guess I want to yeah being
detained
yeah you are for purpose well because I
want to know why you're taking pictures
and then assembling but it's not illegal
okay this is a terrorist terrorist
target it's so illegal she gets it it's
it's against mph no it's not yes it is
I'm a photographer's rights advocate I
know the rules of the Metro yes my team
is you for what purpose what is this is
because I want I want to know who you
are and I wonder why you're taking
pictures of the subway system al-qaeda
would love to buy your picture so I want
to know if you are in cahoots with
al-qaeda to sell these pictures to them
for tariffs permissible that's that's a
crime you understand not committing a
crime by taking - oh no that you're
committing a crime or not but if your
hands out of your pockets when I'm
talking to you okay you do not
understand what I'm saying
so I attend for taking photos you're
being detained until I determine - you
have not committed a crime have I
committed a crime I don't know that's
what I'm investigating right now well
you're gonna cooperate with me or not
may be asking you to take for what
purpose I just told you it's not illegal
to take photos - I already asked you one
time
you have some ID on me yes
yeah back
dice your fingers interlace your fingers
spread your legs where's your idea in my
left pocket no you're not [ __ ] there
[ __ ] yeah
I know it's not you left I'm not stupid
you have an idea says you're a parolee
whatever you plan to me you don't need
one but you're throwing it out there
like it's supposed to be something so
painful
after you throw that out
yes all right good then why is this new
do
like I said as a police officer I am I
never like to detain
I don't know son of our chocolate some
people
did I say it was
under my body explain
I want to determine if you're committing
a crime or not you're getting there
taking pictures just selling about Qaeda
so they can blow up our subway system
I've got a problem that's a crime
this is that clear day or not for the
safety of the public
line the trains
the opportunity legal attack
we're also going to do that
okay this is a terror terrorists party
Subway's at arrogance target can only
happen to London London bombings in the
subway in there you know make this whole
pop this next 20 minutes but no in any
of the terrorist attacks you're kidding
me right
Nadine I'm David I'm sorry no they did
not they did not go down there takes no
yeah no clue what's going on
you're telling me they didn't go down
and take pictures and they didn't know
what they're doing before they planted
bombs in the London subway system
that's just your say a real idea but
aren't taking that subway for that
terrorist
how do I know that I work with the hclu
almost 100 photographers rights well
aware of what's going on I mean you know
I don't why do you have more of a
smidgen of the picture than I do because
we're growing yeah but that that's
telling an intelligence intelligence the
basis on stuff that's going on why do we
need to prove anything to you why why do
we need to do that
and what I'll just submit your name - uh
every time your driver's license gets
scanned take a plane public transit
system where they look at your
identification here did we stop the beat
the day we've searched data beyond the
FBI's hit list that what you want not to
attach the direction you're headed
starting to tame
laid
it's not
which was a private
will you take pictures up
what do you do you know tell me or no
okay so you take pictures of the
infrastructure of the subway system
possibly new up quite a bomb or
something
yes no it's obviously you don't want to
tell me well that raises more suspicion
put your name on a list
you have been arrested for it
you
this film this hot asian now digital
don't please don't open it
don't wanna ruin yourself
we just want to make sure that you know
everyone marry Wanda unless I want to
you there's other images from
642
now that makes our agency this real and
yes I'm a part of other kinds of working
that we are to make my works for a book
my work
and there you don't want to agree
I understand I've gone through many many
times and on my resident know what I
know
she said
the other shirts
I work regularly I could interview about
this subject all the time right sounds
like yeah
I put on I didn't know the rate meal
above the subject meal without food
riots harassment photographers
Association
you're gay CLU okay so do you cou I have
a water at the ACLU talk to Rachel okay
that they were crying
do you not understand
information you know you're taking
pictures of a terrorist target where you
don't see it you see a black and white
Constitutional Rights and take a closer
look you know the one is legal to
photograph a metro what'd you say it's
not but it is quasi public place
constitutional law still applies
I've just been detained for conducting
and perfectly legal activity okay
why were you detained
they explained that they thought at
least three times taking photos what is
my job as a police officer do you know
okay
my job as a police officer is
determining that that individual is
committing a crime if I have reasonable
suspicion that a person may be
committing a crime or even committing a
violation of law I have the legal right
to stop and detain that individual
when I make a determination it is that
that person has in fact routed a crime I
arrest him by the term that is not he or
she is not committing a crime
okay you understand that okay so I have
a legal right as a police officer and an
obligation for the Public Safety to stop
you detain you to determine if you are
in fact committing a crime or not and if
I see that you're taking pictures of not
just the subway system for its hardness
to court its beauty but you're taking
pictures of the infrastructure and how
the how the tracks are laid in the walls
and how thick the walls are and you know
you understand what I'm saying I've been
thinking I don't know that do I
you know it's fine I love you but now
you're saying I take photos of the track
that's not what I said you're not
listening to what I'm saying I'm saying
I'm trying to determine what you're
taking pictures I've got the reasons why
I've no idea what you took notice
it's a camera so I can't see
I'll try to explain you something
if I thought you were
taking pictures for a
terroristic reason you be under arrest
you go to jail
okay
give er a card sir you have a car sir
yeah like tea
sure you spell it right gy LF I eat but
you still write pronounced guilty
it was a joke bachelor sir absolutely
you're Susur
sorry you don't believe in public safety
yep
just that's what they're handing out at
Hollywood and Highland they exact change
I'm sorry if you pay exact change at
Hollywood Highland that's what they're
giving out they have a booth at
Hollywood and Highland
there's MTA officials there Metro
officials there yeah me know so there's
three sheriff's eventual security as
well as associates no petrol
no you have the option you can't exact
change as a boo-boo
a pipe in the center of the booth and
you put your money in there really I
think it's too speeded up kind of so
many people down there that's how it
must be just for today
the place on La Cienega basis
yeah
do you know this completely
it is completely legal to take pictures
in the metro
you know we've had short video I mean we
were getting two years ago we had a
sheriff's escort to protest the
treatment of photographers on the subway
system
I just you may be actually right but I
mean like we believe it was completely
we get we get told different stories and
identify the guilty both sides of the
corner get until the one thing or the
other
yeah which makes it completely noise and
they're like ownership we look at this
as it was completely an unlawful
detainer detaining convictions can I
could see your point
I really can but fairly you don't see
our viewpoint because I know like even
if I took digital pictures you legally
can't look at my photos without a court
order or a warrant you can't go through
my camera oh well I could tell you are
this morning that that's why you have
well that's not the purpose I shouldn't
film because my work is for a book not
for a news I don't need to get it out
there immediately
but like that you're all it's always
like good cop bad cop going on here and
you're different and cut from a
different cloth than your partner I
could see that but you know I trusted my
boss but no but but I'm trying to be
really I am I'm trying to give you a
straight as answers I can I can I can
look at you it I can tell you are very
well school on on your philosophy and
your belief and then you guys have the
open I say cuz you can't arrest me and
bring you to jail you know that's like
I'm doing you know if I was arrested
there me a big lawsuit for you know I
could easily see you guys and you ain't
cost taxpayers money yeah for arresting
me for doing a legal activity in public
you know there's no on that on your
record don't police officers walk that
there's no reprieve I do I do my job and
I get sued I go but the yeah because
there's really no repercussions for you
don't get in trouble you know you aren't
financially held accountable the
taxpayers
it doesn't come out of your pocket for
all nobody at all questionable things
that all the guys do it all the time I
have been shoot I have been disappointed
how's the rustic stay for 10 photos fine
you would have a different case but it's
like is he trying to cite me finish it
here here my other passes like come on I
just wrote your badge numbers honors
this is from this is the one from Wesson
I took down on there like he's a serial
a [ __ ] gonna bust my balls now like
this is tires I'm [ __ ] so fed up with
this [ __ ]
do we have to go down there I'll [ __ ]
pay for another ticket to go down in the
show okay
like what what is it and [ __ ] find an
open change water kidney box
I'm [ __ ] detained at least once a
month I'm threatened with obstruction in
his walks among the [ __ ] doing a
perfectly legal activity is completely
legal to photograph anything in public
in public spaces is public space
I can photograph crime scenes be on the
tape in program police office what every
[ __ ] time I get charged threat with
obstruction
like if you have you're photographing
crime scenes of course like you say
you'd be on your gunshot I got [ __ ]
today from LAPD for photographing so
yeah about the ability stop you for a
fee for words method not skewed
but my interpretation which you make me
think now is our survival
this is a private robbery right private
I'm a comedian question the statue is
again I can cite you the poem it's 1,000
900 public all rules apply then
everything that is allowed in public
there is a booth at the Hollywood and
Highland station with the Metro
representatives in the middle of the
booth there's a high in Highland yeah
there's three sheriff's there that's
Metro officials
I paid $1 by magic see if you have a
receipt show you that's what that's okay